qu'est ce qui m'est arrivé je suis mort
qui veut dire que tout ça n'est qu'un
rêve
non de souvenirs
tous ceux qui sont dans le coma viennent
au même endroit
à dire ici en commun certaines personnes
développent des capacités uniques pour
découvrir leur qualité les gens ont
besoin d'un coup de pouce
essayons de voir ce qui est rend si
particulier
j'étais sur le balcon chef il nous a
appris à survivre ici
nous sommes là pour une raison tous les
gens présents n'avaient pas vraiment
réussi dans la réalité n'a pas encore
compris toutes les règles toi c'est moi
qui ai tiré cesser
si seulement on défait de souvenirs
ce qu'ils arrivent ici non attention
affirme qu'il ya une île dans coma où il
n'y a pas un seul chauffeur
on est toujours à la recherche de ceux
qui peuvent nous aider riez
ma vie est ici maintenant
je me souviens que je pouvais pas être
avec celui que j'aimais
ici oui
ce monde n'a jamais été capable de
mettre en valeur les projets originaux
et insolites
pourquoi aurait-on besoin de la réalité
après ça faut qu'on se réveille
pat réveiller tu comprends
ton corps est ici comme un tueur
3 rien n'est changé la vie dans le coma
est tout aussi réel
vite lance là
[Musique]